the only person who should be concerned
at this point in time should be Mr Imran
Khan who has just been uttering blatant
lies since last night because the
government has nothing to do with the
arrest and the arrest has nothing to do
with the delaying of the elections as he
was projecting into foreign media and in
the domestic media too the police is
only complying with the orders of the
court to arrest him in corruption cases
there are allegations Minister that the
police have been extremely heavy-handed
with members of his party that many have
been injured will you be investigating
those allegations first of all I would
like to make it very clear through your
screen that the police does not have a
single ammunition the police 65
policemen including the Dig operations
of Lahore has been injured because there
has been an you know a regular attack on
the police who's just there without any
MMA to arrest Mr Khan on the arrest
warrants of the court so Mr Khan has to
act responsibly and also should not use
women and children as human Shields just
to avoid his arrest Imran Khan says that
he fears for his life this is a man who
faced an assassination attempt do you
accept that there is a threat there
you see the thing is that if the guy
says that he's uh he has security
threats and to the guy at this in the
same breath Mr Khan says that he's ready
for all political rallies he's out there
but the moment the court asks him to
appear in the court for his corruption
cases he says I have security threat so
you know he has to stick to one thing
and then when he has security threats at
the same time he's inciting violence Mr
Khan denies all allegations against him
and he faces many charges the country is
in economic and political paralysis
right now what is the solution your
government is offering the economic
crisis the reason for the economic
crisis in Pakistan is Mr Khan who put
the country on the verge of defaults by
violating his own IMF program in March
2022. all these these arrest warrants
are for his corruption cases if he says
and if he denies he has to deny that in
the law he has to deny that in the
courtroom he has to deny that with
evidences in the investigation uh cases
that are under trial at the moment there
is meant to be an election because the
allegations that he has put on other
political opponents he jailed them he
put them in jail the entire opposition
was in jail during his time and those
arrest warrants were directly issued by
the Prime Minister office when he was
the Prime Minister
the images from outside his house surely
that is not what you want to send as a
message to the rest of the world about
the state of Pakistan Imran Khan is
responsible for that image building of
Pakistan when he was the Prime Minister
he did the same with media he curtailed
the freedom of expression he put the
entire opposition in jail that was the
message he was sending across the world
when he was the Prime Minister